hello i'm gal gadot hi i'm kristen wiig
hello i'm wonder woman i mean pedro
pascal
and i'm patty jenkins so we're here with
buzzfeed and we are going to do
a super fun quiz called which wonder
woman 1984 character are you
and i'm so interested to see who we all
turn out to be
first how would your bffs describe you
the options
are loyal supportive passionate outgoing
charming and confident
i'm going to pick passionate i'm loyal i
would say
i'm loyal too i would say supply
yeah that's what i was going to say
supportive too pick an 80s song to sing
at karaoke
girls just want to have fun by cindy
lauper another one bites for dust by
queen
oh i wanna dance with somebody
got my answer take on me
by uh-huh lovejack uptown girl
i would be i want to want to dance with
someone i i've definitely karaoke that
song
my answer is a no-brainer because take
on me is still one of my favorite songs
and i still do listen to it
i love i want to dance with somebody but
i wouldn't do it at karaoke who i
wouldn't inflict any song
on anyone from me on karaoke i would and
i don't want anyone to sing i want to
dance with somebody
to me on karaoke i just want to listen
to whitney houston i hate karaoke
i love karaoke girls just want to have
fun why gal just because i love to dance
for this song but i wouldn't sing it in
a karaoke in a karaoke i would probably
sing another one writes for
us pick a movie from 1984 to watch
the karate kid 16 candles beverly hills
cop what a year 1984
footloose ghostbusters the terminator
this is hard
i love all these but it's easy sixteen
candles
is my beverly hills cop is is in second
place for me i was debating between
beverly hills cup to the ghostbusters
and i went to the ghostbusters
how do you decide for me between beverly
hills cop and the terminator
beverly hills cop all right what is one
skill you wish you were really good at
cooking drawing thinking they're dancing
so that i wouldn't torture me i am dying
to be a really good singer it looks
so fun to me so fun and i always say to
great singers like god that must feel so
good so to be able to express that level
of emotion with your voice just
ah kristen you need to pick cooking yeah
pick cooking
for you gal drawing i don't know how to
draw
at all choose a superpower super
strength invisibility
x-ray vision mind reading shape-shifting
flight
flight means flying i think i think i'm
flight
yeah flight yeah and finally pick a
superhero to team up with
black panther batman captain marvel
spider-man
harley quinn and superman so since i
already fought with batman and superman
i will go for harley are you going for
harley i would hope not hitler for sure
it's funny because superman as we know
is one of my other favorite characters
but in this case i'm going to pick
spider-man just because i think i do
love spider-man 2 and i think spider-man
would be really fun
oh my god you would never guess who i am
guess who i am okay
barbara minerva good afternoon
who are you i'm steve trevor me too
are you really trevor guess who i am
i told you i am real wonder woman
thank you buzzfeed be sure to watch
wonder woman 1984.